anybody ever slip a note under lindsay
lohan's door in here anybody oh i did
one night actually at the hotel
you slipped a note under her door yeah
we were both staying in the same hotel
across the hall from each other she was
fine and mean girls i left a note on it
you put i got a rhino 7 000 and i'm up
all night i don't know what i put man i
broke probably something special on it
back off my broccolini
get your life together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
sometimes the porn i watch i feel like
they're using an artificial semen
really yeah there's no i don't know
where you make that ad probably where do
you think it's from i'm sure you stevie
huh it's for sure asian company right
japanese maybe yeah you guys start
already yeah
right you look like you just woke up huh
well we got some bad news
they hated me they did oh yeah ask him
huh
my mind went blank it was a bad dream
for real man twilight zone
they were just silent dude
my dick jokes that i had were you
standing too close to the stool
sometimes i noticed if i'm standing too
close to the stool i don't do as well
no i held the mic i i did everything i
could well
steve had a tough one
it was it was a tough one
it must have been tough because eric
came in and said stevie had a tough
night yeah and it's one of those sets
where like you know like when we're you
know your comic friends when you when
you see them bomb like that you're in
the back giggling yeah it's just you
know what i mean were you guys giggling
or no what i mean
we were it was tough
and it was just and he was like and then
he just like bailed you know he was like
well i figured
[ __ ] it did you he pulled the job i try
to come up with
stuff on the fly like i was talking
about a korean spa
you know i feel like i'm in the hot
korean spa with the angry korean like i
don't i was just trying to do anything
he was listening too much to the silence
yes
you know he was listening too much to
the silence and then he translated that
that as like oh they hate me they hate
me as opposed to like he not realizing
that he's working he went up first it's
a that's a tough room you went up first
well hold on go ahead i want to hear it
from the man right here you guys this is
the question i got a question right here
for black
i got a question right here for captain
black white over here
how are you going to if it's
eric griffin's and friends how are you
going to put your friend he asked to go
up first
can't he goes
traps yeah he sets you up you think he's
gonna yeah but it is what it is is that
what he did no
last time he did the show i'm asking
theo
i'm saying from my perspective steve the
last show you did how was it
same show same spot how'd you do
better than last night so who's that on
and did you go first though
yes same time yeah both times yeah yeah
it was it all new material stevie hell
no oh yes no it was it was the stuff
that i was doing at the hahaha when i
had a great time on your show yeah
you've been doing it for eight minutes
yes it's all new material
i don't have much
i mean the guy's been locked in his
apartment at a senior center for [ __ ]
11 years because his brother doesn't
care about him that much because you
don't even think that it is
shot fire
kind of got deep there i'm just saying
man there and look there you go right
there there's your real friends why
didn't steve be in the picture
he wasn't there in san diego
oh that was that la jolla i was at la
jolla and andrew was doing a theater
then bobby came down you know and so we
just all went to dinner oh no nobody
know he jumped on each other's shows
i think bobby did
you get andrews but but our shows were
at the same time and then you know oh
yeah you know what i mean so it was just
you know what you know the vital mistake
i made the first 30 seconds i wasn't
paying this is like steve you're not
listening like steve you're not paying
attention the dude you were kind of
[ __ ] with that that dude with the
mean mug yeah the philip like
i don't know why i picked him to try to
do crowd work
yeah because he heckled me right away he
was like he's ready yeah
and was your jokes written down and you
knew them in your head
i had it written in my pocket and i had
it did you get it out of your pocket
no oh that's good no it just didn't
matter because when that started
happening you got shook it just my mind
went
blank did you call for eric did you call
for help no that's good how long did i
was up there how long was i up there
um i don't know 20 20 30 seconds
i'm just teasing
he was up there for like two three
minutes he looked at two three minutes
now stevie not now is where you find out
if it's for you or not if you can go
back up well he called me after he
called me and he was just like i'm in a
dark place brother i'm in a dark place
where were you memphis
i don't know i did a randy macho man
savage i don't know what i was doing
yeah i called him i called bob i should
have called you guys oh for some
pointers i would have been supportive
but now you find out if it's for you if
you can go back up and do a [ __ ] hot
set i think i need a day or two dude i'm
trying to tell you yeah you've been up
this week stevie don't dwell on it get
back up this week and get back on the
horse i remember first starting to do
comedy i'm serious and a buddy of mine
was like doing a show at the improv and
he asked me to host
and i had just gotten acl surgery oh so
i had crutches and i said but i was like
i wanna hold crutches what do you mean i
had because i had an acl surgery oh damn
so so i'm like using my crutches you
know
i never forget it like like big
chopsticks yeah man
a lot of his family is deceased dude
yeah a lot you went up you you went up
and hosting got no laughs yeah it was
just ate [ __ ]
right
every
i brought up elon gold i brought up
earthquake
it was like it was monster and i just
was like and everybody was like just
tearing me up because i just was like
doing terrible they ripped you yeah so
like i could easily quit
oh i'm not quitting i just would they
call you yeah they call you name they
call you s'more
no what they call you bro none of that
stuff don't laugh it's not funny it's a
racial slur
you brought it up
and i brought you this hat back from
your country dude hawaii no this is your
hat oh yeah yeah
thank
it's a part of the territory right i
mean this is just like you're gonna get
yeah dude
i mean six years ago i ate all the [ __ ]
at the improv i'm talking and you're
talking about 10 12 minutes set i ate
all the [ __ ] you're eating [ __ ] oh dude
i was like i was in my car i didn't want
to go back out i didn't want to go
because i was on the late show at the
improv yeah i'm in my car i'm like i
just want to go home i get a knock on
the window it's dalia he's what the [ __ ]
you doing like dude i was on the first
show man it went awful oh he's like you
better get the [ __ ] back in there is
that the one you were whining about that
i was talking [ __ ] about you probably
probably bomb
i bombed no i think i think you better
say your problem
live up to them then that's what it is
it was cricket now what was you that's a
great question what was your expectation
yeah
i mean i wasn't expecting the world but
maybe a few chuckles and just a little
some smiles
i'm just asking for smiles i got it was
they hated
yeah it was a great show
it was a great show everybody was i had
a good time it's just that one you know
one of my fingernails down his shirt all
right well you know what that i like
that you shared that i didn't know that
you had that man
everywhere everyone everyone shared that
with me brendan i've never heard that
all right no okay let me expect it i
remember this was even i wasn't
mixed nuts it was where the comedy union
is oh all right it's it was called mixed
nuts at the time a little racist super
black seems racist so like it's a black
room color
yeah yeah so then there's uh uh j
anthony brown old school black comic
he's hosting he's on stage and he's
killing i mean killing yeah the crowd is
like ah
people wearing suits people beating each
other with their canes it was crazy yeah
so then all the comics standing in the
back he didn't know who was next so
we're all standing there right and he
goes who next
you know and i'm standing in the front
literally all the comics took a step
back you know nobody wanted to go up and
i was like i'll go up
and he was like he brings me up you
couldn't move work he still had the bad
knee no no that's a different time so
then like two minutes two minutes into
my set he's giving me the light
you know and i'm like yeah i go like
this damn i got the light already i get
off he goes up and he does about 15 to
20 minutes about how bad i was
i even remember one of the jokes he was
like [ __ ] you got the light people
setting a woman on fire to get you off
stage
and he just was like going in on me man
and i'm standing and i'm standing in the
back no comics want to come near me
because you don't want the energy on you
you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah somebody you don't want that
bomb energy on you and i just was
looking
because you cheer locker rooms with a
blue corner red corner in that blue
corner the guy would fight before you go
out and i hope he [ __ ] wins because
if not he comes back their eyes all
[ __ ] up bleeding everywhere if the guy
was lost he was in my corner i'd go to
the bathroom so he'd go in there get a
[ __ ] get out because i didn't want to
you don't want to see that but it must
be like in football if like you just
fumbled
and then the other team ran back for a
touchdown and you got to walk to the
sidelines that's the worst everybody's
looking at you like yeah damn dude you
hold the ball [ __ ] that's your job
i imagine being a kicker imagine being
scott norwood missing the kick you
missed a super bowl winning kick yeah
and you got to walk to the sideline who
wants to be near that guy
that was steve last night
he was the kicker
yeah db bill like the kicker
i want to hear uh theo's last bad uh
experience
oh man i've been doing so long bombs
dude that's some bombs
san francisco that was outside um oh
yeah that was a nightmare how long was
that
outdoor show it was like a harvey milk
conference it was like
[Applause]
people out there drinking milk writing
harvey on the cart and people maybe it
was the i hey gays shirt that he had
could
but no dude and it was probably 5 000
people outside it was like lining like
from one it was like they set up a stage
and it was kind of cool you could see it
at a capitol building in the distance it
was freaking dope man
and you got on stage and it was outdoors
so you could the second somebody laughed
it just went up in the air
just dissipated yeah
but
i don't know if they laughed about one
dude i heard sneeze about a hundred
yards away that's how bad it was going
oh you heard that yeah
i even said bless you
it was going man
you heard him go thank you
mark norman in the pandemic he was doing
shows outside at like [ __ ] the park
in new york he said i was bombing so bad
i heard actual crickets she's outside of
the car
actual crickets dang boy that's some
bomb yeah when you bomb too and you come
back and like
oh
you know people don't want to say no
it's just hard you don't want to see
nobody yeah and that's not just nothing
anybody can say there's nothing anybody
can say yeah
and that's why we laughed at you yeah if
there's a comedy like when you bomb
you're like
what you want me to say oh you get them
next time like it's like striking out
tonight it's like striking out yeah you
bombed it is kind of fun to just tell
somebody shut up that they bombed yeah
damned all you bombed yeah or get up and
be like damn that dude bombed yeah you
gotta address it yeah it's kind of i
think it is especially when like
especially when like if the person
it sucks when the person don't realize
they bombed like those are the people i
can't stand oh when they come back do i
cry yeah i was like people make it in
this business a lot of times too yeah
they do that yeah well they justify it
it's all they're just so out of touch oh
i don't know about the green room
i knew i ate [ __ ]
i wanted to hide under a rock everybody
knows that's it yeah i wanted to hide
phil your boy is fighting this saturday
man we talking about the diamond dust
and pouring trying to trying to get that
light weight belt son that strap chase
connor he beat connor he said you know
what i'm gonna go for the money plan i'm
gonna take connor and then i'm gonna
fight for the strap he's fighting
charles de bronx oliveira this saturday
son this is it man you know i can't
believe it i'm gonna be over there i
can't wait to see what happens i'm going
to be sitting there and be standing up
give me front row and a thong i'm going
to be as close as i can get baby filled
with the light of the lord dog cheering
on the diamond baby put your money where
your mouth is man because ufc 269 is
here either watch theo on tv or watch it
with your boy here we're doing a fight
companion this saturday you can watch
theo and myself whatever you want to do
but bet on it make money with draftkings
the official sports betting partner the
ufc and they have quite the offer for
you guys uh
all new users download the top-rated
draftkings sportsbook app now and use
the promo code k-a-t-s when you sign up
bet on the parlay of fighters to win
saturday night for ufc 269 and take
advantage of my special odds boost
that's promo code k-a-t-s
only at draftking sports book i got tied
to ivasa and uh dustin poirier and cody
garbrandt man so here's the picks and
kogo yup if you scroll down you see
brennan shops picks under the boost tab
all right it's the odds boost tab it's
brendan schaub's picks just head to the
app right now the draftkings app new
existing customers we got you man bet on
it get your odds boosted one of his
picks was a chicken marsala which is
very interesting one of my picks was
chicken fried steak whatever man it's
the official sports betting partner of
ufc use promo code k-a-t-s all new users
download the top-rated draftkings
sportsbook app now use promo code cats
must be 2-1 or older 21
n-j-p-a-n-i-n-m-i
or v-a only restrictions applies to
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
gambling problem call 100 gambler or in
virginia 888 532 3500. again my picks
are cody garbrandt tied to avasa and
dustin the diamond poirier baby
what's this nick uh we got another uh
dope original music uh
so submission and it addressed some of
the criticism that eric had from other
musical performers so far yeah
really cats on the phone
and the video is like all the rappers
have to be white though i'm just
wondering
i see you brendan i see you we'll see
what i can do
hey what up crew
y'all said you were looking for a black
rapper and some jamaican [ __ ]
you see the color
hey what up stevie
hey it's the king and the stink
[Music]
i'm just trying to spread some
positivity and that's a fact taking a
sting and do anything and i've been on a
fun to jump every person that i meet i
gotta tell them look it up it's the
stuff it's the [ __ ] that you've been
lacking in your mind so i'm addicted to
it baby
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i still hate my cartoon but whatever
you hate yours
oh my god look at me i was cute as a kid
where's my top lip eight inches
you do got that real grill baby damn boy
man yeah that's kyle hoover from
lancaster pennsylvania good job good job
that was great man
oh damn
all the music is coming together huh
yeah those videos that's a fun vibe yeah
it seemed like you didn't like it stevie
looks like my dad actually but [ __ ]
younger and smaller in asia
yeah yeah i swear to god i'm gonna bring
a let me get a picture of my dad and
send it to you next you can put it in
yeah i'd like to meet i'd like to meet
him oh oh this is eric putting on some
vocals yeah for the thick boy
so yeah just basically give it a run
through a couple times i feel like you
have
dr dre's house this is the random ones
we got from brows but you guys yeah the
ones that the better one is when you
already hear steve listening to the
finished product that's when we were
like
[Music]
that's like some dude's house that like
made songs for jay-z
you know we're in a nice area it wasn't
even a nice necessarily nice area but
like that it's like one of these like
hidden gems yeah because i was like oh
i've never seen it and i went in i was
like god damn yeah we're in a hidden gem
like a fitness place or something not a
hidden gem
hidden gem yeah you're a treasure hunt
yeah you put down some vocals then
stevie put some music too huh yeah yeah
yeah there's a whole plan yeah obviously
right album now what about this though
stephen do you see yourself making a
comeback or do you think that that's it
he's getting up this [ __ ] week stevie
no i got it up i got others i have to
show up to yeah we have to we're doing
scissors bro live podcast yeah that's
whatever that that's a whole lot no
that's a home game home games don't
count
you got to go
you want to get on friday i'll get you a
spot friday or saturday somewhere in l.a
you want this hat you want to say
something near people you got to get you
got to get back up
yeah i'll get you back up you want me to
get your spot yeah i mean i'm going to
get back up i'm going to i'm not going
to quit but you're not going to just do
this yeah i'm going to quit i'm not
letting them win right now get back on
the heel you're fighting yourself yeah
exactly
i'm my own enemy you're fighting that's
all that's what would your grandfather
say dude get back
he would just he would just turn away
from me like
would he yeah last night he would have
stevie i'm gonna text you tonight if you
don't have a spot in l.a by yeah i'm
gonna get you one it was it was if your
dad was in the crowd last night
you know what i mean
a joint no
yeah i had it out and everything oh i
feel like that's a good idea wait why
are you having that why do you even have
it though i feel like you're making it
sponsorship it was like cbd with a
little bit of thc i had it out he's
going down a weird road bubba
did you try though were you like i was
trying to do it
there's nothing sadder than you
masturbating yourself he was like oh you
can do this press masturbation after you
bomb come on
if you bomb and then reward yourself
yeah you don't deserve it i didn't even
deserve to beat off
the big dick out after you
do well this week it's all heartbreaking
you're getting up this week but do you
see him getting back up there yes
okay yeah i ain't quit
you know what he needs to do
he used to record himself i didn't quit
there you go yeah yeah he's not
recording he's not recording himself you
need to record yourself so you can be
like like watching myself podcast i
don't like listening nobody likes how
you get back i
it's different this isn't your stand-up
dog you got to get back on the makimaki
because you're not doing the same thing
over and over on this
what is that stand up are you delinquent
you got to bring a professional approach
dog so you should be recording it listen
to it see what hits yeah but you might
be like oh i didn't say that joke right
you guys have done that all the
time do everybody else still you've done
that i'll listen to myself from the
night before and and before i do the
next set that night you listen to
yourself over i'll listen to you tell us
on my set as i'm going to do a spot yeah
you listen to like this
yeah
cause you got you actually get more
things you go oh i should say this yeah
you miss things you have an idea it'll
make you laugh like oh this is funny
there's certain tags you might say on
stage you forget you said it but he's
just starting out too he might not even
turn any of that capability yeah
what you're talking about now you're
going to be laughing at yourself in like
a year and he could be horrible at it
yeah i could there's that that's the
possibility
i mean i'm not saying i hope not but i'm
just saying you know you never know you
might find something else you might do
coaching softball you might do something
else that's super negative delivering
ice cream
this guy's got a debate club for us
does he have like an ice cream truck
is ryan from texas
stevie what's up big griff
what's up there what's up brandon what's
up nick what's up chin in the neck brace
what's up with that
yeah nick where's the debate where's the
neck brace staple center just changed
its name to the crypto.com arena
you like it you hate it or what would
you name it i hate when they change it
gang gang buzz buzz i hate when they
change it like growing up as a kid it
was always mile high stadium in denver
now it's like in vasco that's not even
in vasco anymore how much is it to
change nick how much how much does it
cost to change that it's like 700
million
crypto.com or paid for that the naming
rights that's about my pay grade yeah
but dude if the crypto called this show
and was like we want to change it to
king and the crypto sting
and they gave you guys whatever money oh
that would be yeah yeah yeah what about
the blood and the cryptos would be good
wouldn't it be something
nerds just trading coins yeah
a couple of doge bros
i hate when they change the [ __ ]
names though do y'all think crypto is
going to stick around and be a real
dealer seems like it though right
they're everywhere they're the main
sponsor of the ufc now
this they got [ __ ] uh damon doing
their
ads oh no that's the app coinbase they
had matt damon doing their ads yeah man
that makes you want to [ __ ] buy chris
a lot there's a lot of money in that
stuff like and like these people are
like they're up or upper one percent
they got a lot of money in that y'all
invested right
in crypto i have some crypto but i'm not
like
i still got some doge coins yeah you
know so yeah i thought i was gonna get a
dogecoin house because i thought i was
gonna be like oh my god you know but now
it's just like whatever just a few
thousand and he's saying do we like it
when they change or what should they
change the name to yeah uh or what would
you change it if you could change
anything we already got theos i like
that crypts and bloods arena crypto and
blood blood and cryptos yeah blood and
kryptos
that's pretty good would you name it
i don't even have an answer for that i
don't even know what he's saying he's
still shook
he can't you still think about that
first joke
you seem like you got high you do some
drugs steven doesn't he well you
wouldn't know
that's a good point you tell us
to test it out who smoked it my neighbor
i go hey dude test this out because i
didn't know how much thc was in it so
he's like dude this is garbage if you
want a joint i'll give you one i'm like
nah i just don't want it
is that how you when you're buying drugs
you just smell oh you got a gram on you
that's just likes with fentanyl
there's some fentanyl in that man i'm
gonna pass for that you're like one of
those airport drug dogs
remember i remember being so high at
school and the drug dog came that day
and i was high as hell dude but i didn't
have any weed on me i was just high and
i was like i remember asking the cop can
they just smell if you're real high
doug do you remember when they had the
the covet dogs were the dogs that could
smell covenant
because i tore it all during the
pandemic there was a they had dogs that
could smell
it oof that's something somebody's like
what the [ __ ] like sorry get out of here
they're throwing people out cover
sniffing dogs
yeah absolutely we've got to get the
[ __ ] back on the grind son
how do they say
there's one right there look at him in
the gym
yeah you practicing right now he ain't
there [ __ ] guess
that's insane bro are you kidding me
i'm telling you some people didn't make
their flights because it's [ __ ]
that's cool [ __ ] labrador retriever
said you smelled like
[ __ ] when you want to have drugs on you
dude we got to get somebody on the
flight that has not made their flight
because they got hit by a coach
i saw multiple people get turned down
i promise like god damn this is good a
lot of people don't even know they even
have it yeah yeah it's not like it hits
everybody the same anyway so you could
be asymptomatic walking around with kova
did not know until a dog is like
i think you're good now yeah well you
people only get tested because you have
to when i was doing a pilot i had to i
was getting tested three times a week oh
my brother said he saw your commercial
on monday night football for ibm or
something oh damn you making this money
huh bill gates over here
rich as [ __ ] now
what you usually look at you you shut up
yeah you don't want to hear you him
living he got crystals in his house
he always got his kid on his instagram
with like a fur coat on
[ __ ] [ __ ] dope chain get up man
ibm ain't calling me yeah computers
that's a big deal all these computers
that's the national campaign
probably more than you got paid for
bombing the other one thousand dollars
that's two commas
stevie with that playing that little iwo
jima here he is right here griff look at
him right there oh my god you're testing
for diabetes dude right there
i knew something was different about
eric you're different though
the big leagues was your girl like ooh
hercules hercules yeah she loves
spending my money
damn good for you man yeah proposals
every morning yeah you still doing that
sometimes
lately she takes it off you know yeah
she takes it off yeah saying that [ __ ]
man because then she likes to cry she
gets very emotional so she really wants
to feel that you know you know i do
something different every time you know
what i mean i'll be like no i don't know
what you mean man you gotta quit
spreading that [ __ ] around really you
need to try something then other girls
be romantic with your girls that's the
problem man yeah be romantic should have
popped out two huge ass babies
ruined because of you
these ufc babies coming out
they needed a yeah and a doctor
yeah dude one of the doctors was uh no
nonsense keith peterson
smoking a cigarette
you know an irv dean pops in like that
they had announcers at the park
they said the baby can't breathe herb
said let it go let it go
dana white didn't pay you enough
[Laughter]
uh we got some
cats confessions oh yeah oh i love these
some good ones this week well hopefully
by the end of this episode we shake
stevia i've never seen stevie like this
shake it off dawg you're cool i'm good
i'm no i'm good you're doing
interception i'm good i'm good i'm just
you know you're getting up just give me
a day you think you're thinking about
some material right now no no no no it's
tuesday what do you mean that was on
sunday uh rub on this bottle
monday it was last night
it's fresh oh it's fresh it's just bad
luck and he said he didn't sleep
yeah
there you go yeah bad yeah let's do some
confessions here we go yeah
what's up king of steam crew i've been
dating my girlfriend for the last two
years is this first time we hooked up i
used a boner pill and she said that i
performed really well and that's the
reason why she started dating me
and then the
second and third time i didn't use one
she started questioning i was asking you
know what happened and so
for the last two years
every other day i take a viagra just to
keep it crazy
that blood pressure
there ain't nothing wrong with that but
how you gonna dick your girl down with
some turbo dick energy and then just go
away i'm with her like where's that
[ __ ] energy where's that big dick
because he made her feel insecure yeah
she does think it's about good job they
always think it's about them they're
always like am i ugly is it because of
me it's just like i mentioned a lot of
things going on he's dependent on the
pill to get hard then like well sounds
like you really laid some good dick down
and she's like where's that same energy
and then well it sounded like he needed
to start taking some vitamins and work
out or something yeah sounds like he
like you know what i mean right
i mean i remember taking one of them
once from the gas station dude in miami
one time oh no rhino 7000 hell yo that's
that jon jones [ __ ] dog oh dude this
stuff bro no it made my freaking nose
bleed dude
so no joke bro i'm making love to this
woman this nice lady dropping that one
like the blood couldn't didn't know
where to go it was like oh it's like a
ufc fight i met at like this nice
seafood restaurant dude i don't remember
her name she was a little bit older
there you go rhino sevens this was the
early dude this was the early recipe it
was rocky bro wow dude my foot swolled
up i couldn't get one of my [ __ ]
shoes on yeah i couldn't lace it fully
so it was making things hard that wasn't
supposed to be hard
it was a unique your upper lip got
harder
which i barely have yeah
yeah
it showed up for a second
oh oh damn they're on eight now oh no
they're way for the they've definitely
come and live like on batch 14 now but
the seven's best
oh rhino 69. the sevens were putting
people to sleep but i remember making
love and my nose just starts
were you on top huh
did you i was wherever i could get in
bud i remember that
10 000.
i think i was in side control i'm not
that good at sex
don't you go
actually can we get some confirmation
ladies send in something like it was
that daddy's love you man phil was in
half guard trying to pass like full
mouth yeah [ __ ] what is happening right
now that'd be great to get something why
do you keep calling me big gene that
would be huh yeah it'd be great if like
women send in confessions yeah i slept
with theo
that'd be totally fine send in some
audio confessions yeah that'd be great
totally fine yeah
but you got to send them in about
everybody i don't want to be the only
one well
i don't know
oh now y'all don't want to fall
oh you're taking your boner pill and
going home huh we all show up to the
court huh i see what's going on
everything has to be pre-2014
oh there you go you got to be a real
risk taker to go to the gas station pop
on those rhino seven thousands
i don't even i don't wanna why did you
do that though that you knew you knew
like i ain't gonna be able to get it
anxiety i got too much anxiety bro he's
probably doing cocaine at the time could
have been maybe you would help yourself
or something i don't remember but i had
a lot of anxiety i just met this woman i
don't know where it's late at night
all those things make me nervous so i'm
like anxiety kicks in yeah two in the
afternoon i'll make love to anybody yeah
but when it hits about 5 30 6 45 son i
get too much nervous energy in me
hey chin i uh i heard a guy who
i won't say his name but you know who he
is i was talking about kratom and he was
like kratom a lot of guys [ __ ] with
their erections yep you say i can't get
hard off kratom really i said i use it
every day dude my dick heart is wrong
what is that you know what i ate them
yeah chin hit it
it's a leaf it's from thailand i believe
in indonesia and it all is basically a
leaf that's dried up and then ground up
so it's just a natural product but then
i think thai farmers would use it to
stay up and feel better you just
describe also cocaine
no the cocaine is processed right
cocaine's process are you talking about
opium
similar receptors but it doesn't it's
not really considered an opioid but it
it messes with the same receptor so it's
it's a very controversial thing plant
kratom has addicted opioids i use it
every year yeah
i don't encourage people to use it just
research it yourself oh i encourage you
to use this almost you've talked what
yeah
a year are you hearing what you're
talking about because it where's my back
up last night you bring your cradle he's
on i always got your back dude i always
got your back anything about dick you
just come to me it is interesting how
you yeah the vietnamese bro know what's
up so that's in vietnam
huh yeah you can get it here though i
said i swear by kratom oh you do my
limitless bill you'll take it every day
every single day how much
with some with some uh green tea oh damn
with some matcha yeah that's that black
panther yeah you're gonna wait and then
i put a banana in
turmeric i'll put that's the shade wake
up at a panda express
dude i'm about to be 50. i gotta like
yeah be on it yeah and my girl wants to
have babies and [ __ ] i'm starting life
late you're gonna have a yeah i have a
family she wants to so i'm like and i i
i i
didn't know if i was gonna do that so
now i'm like damn dad it's time to do it
so i gotta like that's why i'm down 40
pounds in body fat and i'm trying i just
got a rolling machine oh so you're doing
it yeah you mean
yourself watching me like hydro
you got the new house are you and your
girl trying like you know she's not
because she's
very much like i
[Applause]
i'll be better next time theo i know you
see a lot of bros at the shows man a lot
of them losing their hair man two out of
three bros will experience some form of
hair loss by the time they're 30 oh yeah
bro some guy left hair in the seat the
other night we found a bunch of hair and
we tried to chase somebody out in the
parking lot and and nobody they're like
oh we think we saw him but we don't know
good man and keeps offers simple
stress-free way to keep your hair yep
there's only two fda approved
medications to treat hair loss and
keeps offers both oh my god discreet
little package shows up proven results
keep has more five star reviews than any
of its competitors prevention is key
treatments take four to six months to
see results so act right now yup
prevention is key treatments can take
four to six months as he said to see
results so like fast if you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss go to
k e
e p s dot com slash k a t s to receive
that first month baby you want that
treatment don't you you want to be
treated well that's keeps k-e-e-p-s dot
com slash cats to get your first month
free
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash cats i keep spelling it
out for you dude thanks dude
we got another next confession two more
really good okay all right well now what
if the confession was i was at a show
last night
[Laughter]
got an anonymous confession here um
my dad a few years ago passed away you
know loved him very close to him and um
when he had passed away
uh
you know it just happened
and uh one thing i thought was uh
gilman's got some credit still
so i went and uh
maxed out
pretty much all his credit cards he had
left for stuff that i needed computer
um some [ __ ] for my car all kinds of
[ __ ]
and uh
never came back on me so
i mean who gives a [ __ ] at this point
you know
but uh yeah i just wanted to get that
out there that i
took all his credit cards after he died
and
[ __ ] spent the [ __ ] out of him
so uh anyways thanks guys for letting me
confess uh
gang gang buzz buzz i'm gonna say black
guy
no that's that's that's that's feeling
white dude that's a white question
because he's dead no i'll tell you why i
don't have a problem with this because
in our country
the the inheritance laws
that they take 40
anyway like like if you you know like
unless you have a living trust and
unless you have that kind of stuff in
place where you make sure your money
goes which you should which you make
sure you do that because if you don't
they take a lot of money when you're
when you're when you die yeah and so
it's that that so you know that's what's
gonna happen like when bill gates dies
you know they're gonna the government's
like well all right thanks give us these
billions that's how that's what happens
so that guy was like you know what i'm
not getting whatever so give me give me
some computers and stuff dude if bill
gates dies we could probably save the
inner cities of america i feel like do
you feel like we'd ever get enough money
back to like
well did you see what happened with uh
elon musk the i forget who the people
who run the hunger [ __ ] was like man six
billion dollar six billion dollars would
cure
uh hunger in the world and he was like
cool if you can prove that i'll give you
six billion dollars yeah he was like
yeah and then they're like
well no we don't mean like cured help
out he's gotta get the phone no because
he also said to them open up your books
that's what he said he's saying he's six
million if you can't
they couldn't do it i love that i love
that he's like that i love that he's
like that cause now he's like he got
three hundred billion dollars six
million actually you know she's waiting
for a billion billion yeah the richest
man in the world now
he was like she yeah he's the closest to
a trillionaire
he was like show me if you can prove it
would help i'll give you 6 million right
now what about being a grillionaire dude
let me see your grill
is that like you have like
we need to get paul wall back on this
baby yeah he just got that grill in
there
wait wait wait paul wall was here paul
wall yeah came on the show paul wall
davis champ people's champ he was here
yes
boy he said he sent us grills too
yeah he was on the show
him and jelly roll he listens with his
family that's crazy yeah he has a
freaking family which you're going to
have soon and you could have one day if
you get your act together and if you do
better at your job
if you didn't have performance anxiety
that's a good
i'm gonna get that family i better get
in there and get it fast
we just need your girl to pull the
goalie how how long do you have to be
having sex to get a baby you think you
know what if you have the nut all the
way into this this is no hit and miss
[ __ ] no it depends on the
her oh yeah pre-cum yeah you gotta have
a strong batch of it though now stevie
really stressed out yeah
steve never pulls out
no i do i do the roly-poly the rollie
what's the really positive move you
you do it
no it's to prevent you from nutting you
just move backwards yeah yeah i don't
know why i do the role yeah actually the
role's pretty cool
the role's pretty good what are the
girls on top steve no
the role is very gentle
you just pull out what you're wrong he
ain't being on the bottom bro
yeah no he
[Applause]
yeah i'm a human i like it i'm a human
yeah you like going to the bunch jackie
chan if you do a backflip afternoon it's
not a flip it's a roll there's a
difference and then they show the
outtakes after messes up his neck and
[ __ ]
what it just comes in his own face
puts his own eyes out
he said it which probably doesn't take
much
what else you got nick uh we got we'll
actually do two more because this one
can also just like the last one double
as a race my case so
theo okay i really like this segment by
the way keep this i really liked it yeah
was white guy too the last yeah i'm
going white yo
so i used to work as a secret shopper at
the macy's with two other dudes puerto
ricans i slowly started noticing that
they was wearing polo ralph lauren and
all these foreign brands and i'm like
damn what the [ __ ] so you know next
thing you know we end up all
admitting to each other that we started
still a little bit to search and then we
all grouped together and just started
stealing everything is this the
all the losers
stealing everything like fifteen hundred
dollars worth every single night it'd be
a huge issue but we rightly finished but
we set up all the cameras so where we
couldn't get caught so it just felt like
a height so stevie with you don't even
feel bad too red but man
yeah
i like your saint compared to that well
i like how he immediately he was like he
went right to the criminal in the room
don't feel too bad man oh i'm a saint i
did nothing wrong this guy's one of the
leaders in [ __ ] california i couldn't
even understand what he was saying so
he's right
that's yonkers or something he was a
secret shopper so like someone was he
yeah yeah that is new york
inside job it's pretty good dominican as
[ __ ] yeah that's new york sometimes you
had a secret shopper man i don't know
what is a secret shop it's like you ever
see that black dude that has like white
skin
you know what i'm talking about
is the albino yeah like the albino yeah
i always go over that dude and i'm like
i know you a secret shop yeah
you know so you just go to random albino
dudes in a store you the secret shopper
right
no i just say hey fam you know so i know
yeah
i give them that wink i say i know
i'm just saying hey man what are they
doing you know what i'm saying give me
some intel sometimes i like to think
when i get on plane people think i'm the
marshal you know there's a marshal on
the flight yeah i come on that [ __ ] my
tattoos are i'm like oh they probably
think i'm the marshal
no
no dude maybe the marshall mellow
nobody thinks you're the [ __ ] marshal
you don't think so on the flag like if
[ __ ] goes down you're like oh that guy's
got this i know there's a real marshall
somewhere you dress like a thick girl
going to coachella dude there's no way
anybody thinks you don't
maybe they think i'm dressing like that
like they're not just you know like to
fit in
no all right who do they think is the
marshal of this group
no not theodore you can't hang out with
their hair not with that haircut eric
eric yeah aaron
he looks like a sheriff
sheriff yeah sit down
at least i was like when i worked with
kids i had like a he had to go to my
principal voice enough enough yeah
sometimes you gotta do that hey that's
all you gotta do
it's a timber in your voice it makes
people go okay i'm sorry yeah a marshall
you'd be a good marshal eric yeah well
in my next life i knew a real marshall
he's like that [ __ ] sucks man nothing
ever happens you say i'm flying all
around the goddamn country nothing ever
happens eating them bisque off cookies
yeah
that's how you keep your mask off yeah
just sip it or get a camel back a lot of
people do that now you'll see people on
there with camelbacks just sucking on
them dude we're on a flight in this uh
my boy mark harley sat next to this old
lady she goes she can be up front right
away i'm a stickler a mask
so i need you to leave your mask on he's
like well i'm drinking she's like i
don't care in between drinks put that
mask on whoa
well [ __ ] you working overtime today
then cause
i'm loosey-goosey with this mask [ __ ]
she was all up on him the whole flight
this should be something that you should
wake him up
it's under your nose sir oh dude i had
an erection one time on the flight right
the light i get erections on flights the
lady wakes me up
and says sir your body i talked about
this before on what do you mean your
business owner yeah she said your body
she said sir your body then orders a
blanket for me from the flight attendant
fair because it was so big huh yeah yeah
you were enticing her she was always
because i was excuse me
sure your dick is in my face yeah
it was like it was like it was like
smelling brownies you know the name she
was like did you see nick cannon not a
dick next to me right now mckenna was
hosting a show
and
just had his dick out bro oh let me see
you
massive dick let me see
he's in a fitted suit and his dick there
it is yeah i mean this dude has a
[ __ ] cannon on him nope
yes what are you guys talking about nick
look at that
he did a show like that oh
you got a python he didn't say anything
no no he hasn't you have to know no no
no that thing that's big dick life man
dude you got a big dick
you know what happened was he was
flirting with somebody and then they
were like you got to go the thing filled
up [ __ ] right here yeah the game the
game always used to post photos and he
just said
what's it is that is oh my god
christ it looks like those uh those
clams that you guys ate yeah yeah
theo was on a delta flight doing this
wait he'll put this on his instagram
yeah he put hashtag well i figured he
put his hashtags were hilarious though
he stopped doing it
he probably got banned
dang boy the game's known to mess with
the boys though
we got to get out there stevie we got to
get you out there put something tight on
the tent real tight damn steve you do
[ __ ] pull ups on that big dick dog
okay it's gonna have to be real love
love to see you do a [ __ ] back flip
out after that no we might have to
shrink wrap you to see that thing
but did you get the blanket what
happened oh yeah the lady brought the
blanket over and i just thought it was
absolute addiction and i looked at the
lady's husband and i said you see what's
going on here sir so you cool with this
he was like yeah
yeah
he wanted he wanted you to come over
like i just take my wife down how do you
guys get boners on flights i don't know
the second we leave the the ground me
too i got that space dead yeah is it the
stewardess just be honest no it's the
arrow it's just being in the air i don't
like being erection on earth yeah i
don't like being above a thousand feet
with my dick brandon starts getting away
from his wife he like
my dick smells it dude
we flying away
where up and down
this [ __ ] is old school at emirates
southwest is always a gay dude i'm like
back up dog back the [ __ ] up man oh
you're probably a little magnet for that
huh no they all upon me oh yeah them
little gators running wake me up sir are
you feeling okay yeah [ __ ] i'm sleeping
man i love you back up dog yeah you know
you're a little more friendly than that
yeah
that's what the problem is
he got just a friendly face man they
said hey marshall yeah
you must be the marshall right
i think i got a marshall law up in here
i got a little crime maybe i think some
crime could be happening in my butt
sir they just had a small crime in my
butt if you want to check it out
have you ever have you ever had sex on a
plane in the background have you gone
with the stewardesses what they call
that the miles way too big for that yeah
i i'm i'm in the back i'm like this i i
i tell you i've never had the [ __ ] in
the because you haven't every time oh
yeah i don't i don't give a [ __ ] yeah i
don't know why people can't
act like i'm on the phone
i hit my phone up act like i'm talking
on the phone even though we're ten
thousand feet in the air
and you went in the bathroom to talk
about the phone yeah
10 minutes later
it's a nightmare oh it's exhausting the
cleanup the cleanup is always longer
than the delivery
man piece just the beast in there so you
just know i just know i gotta go take a
shower as soon as i land and these
underwear are done yeah but these
underwear are done you [ __ ] in your
pants
you can't yeah it's this big and i was
even bigger you cannot wipe your ass
properly in an airplane
there's not enough room there's not
enough room i'll keep that in there yeah
there's not enough room i mean i grabbed
the
that blue water tastes good hell yeah so
you can't gator it baby
it's physically impossible for you even
if some finance steward is like hey
marshall nothing
you're like what are we going to happen
the door had to be open there ain't no
fun though every now and then there'll
be a nice looking so you on delta no i
use united it's some every now and then
on delta you see a nice looking stuff no
i'm telling jetblue has some baddie
stuff you guys been with one before a
stewardess yeah
i don't know
i don't know i might have
you know you've slipped your number oh
i'm definitely walking off walking off
the plane you're like yeah beginning to
call back the difference during yeah
right right right never got a call back
oh i remember writing my this long note
to a girl one time in new york at a
restaurant too much you did oh it was so
so thirsty you expressed your love for
it oh she'll respond back
just a long note like how [ __ ] long
is this [ __ ] like anybody gonna reply
what'd you write in there with just some
different stuff about the restaurant and
her
would you love her
yeah you ever write on the receipt like
you know like i've done that yeah you
ever had a girl write her number on the
receipt
yeah but yeah i didn't call
because
you know
what you think stephen they're not all
winners yeah yeah
anybody ever slip a note under lindsay
lohan's door in here anybody oh i did
one night actually at a hotel
you slipped a note under her door yeah
we were both staying in the same hotel
across the hall from each other she was
fine and mean girls i left a note on it
you put i got a rhino 7 000 and i'm up
all night i don't know what i put man i
wrote probably something special on it
[Laughter]
i really gotta hear that what something
special and please play some romantic
music while he's saying it tell us to
lindsay lohan
minneapolis
the state of minneapolis
yeah i was like good evening i think it
started with good evening because it was
after about 4 30 i remember yeah
like good evening yeah
good evening fancy that we're both
staying here
you know what a beautiful town you know
minneapolis was a lot
smaller i happen to be in town for work
what about you
don't answer that
uh
[Laughter]
so then when security came knocking on
your door then what happened i said hey
if you're trying to meet somebody for a
drink or something later i happen to be
staying right across the hall hit me up
was it crazy lindsay lohan though but or
like it was probably pretty cool she's
being bad though oh yeah she's a freak
very talented too super did you see her
listen wait pull that up because she had
a list of the people she's had sex with
like parent trap she put her
dog yeah i would have left a note i
would have left a drawing yeah yeah yeah
yeah but that's what i look like this is
a real thing
i was also nine i was into it oh there
you go it was an adult parent trial she
don't got all the people they got it
covered up but this was her list there
was a list yeah she made a little tom
farrell justin timberlake
james franco
i love how some of them levine some of
the people had a good enough publicist
to get their names scratched out and
some people didn't yeah theo could have
been on that list he's probably on that
but go back to it where would theo be on
the list in terms of like be in the
middle you know what i mean uh
yeah i'd say 12 13. i love how the list
is written on this category's card
that's how it i love yeah
wow this is like like it's like 1
through 12 it's just like you know
you know like the bigger dicks are on
the left and like you know what i mean
yeah
how does she categorize this i don't
know but she got heath ledger before he
passed away yeah r.i.p he can't even
defend himself though there you go
yeah
uh one more confession this one's a
little bit more innocent we'll go on a
lighter note and then a couple more uh
what's up fellas this is uh
so about two years ago i entered a a
bass fishing tournament in the uh in the
louisiana area so the way these work is
you can only catch fish
that are like in the river or in the
lake like natural fish
so i entered this tournament it was for
a benefit for a high school baseball
team so what i did is i went and caught
fish in a pond the day before like not
connected to the river
and put them in a trap in the water when
i launched my boat for the bass
tournament i drove all the way up the
river to where this was went and got the
fish out of the pond put them in my boat
and uh
there were some big fish ended up
winning the
tournament by about a pound and one a
thousand dollars yeah so i feel pretty
bad about it uh
sorry high baseball team
okay we cheated cheater i helped that
guy out he said his name he said the
city and the high school so yeah
he cheated that's all he cheated
yeah
you better believe it tournament they
take it very seriously [ __ ] for fishing
tournaments yeah
have you guys done any tournaments in
korea
here we go man
like a squid game
like a squid game thing but fishing yeah
yeah i'm just asking you everybody
in korea
right dude i'm about to punch you in the
[ __ ] arm man
i always want to punch i don't know and
the level the level of asian racism that
comes out of his mouth
i love these people man he's just poking
fun but you got a little malicious
intent what are you serious about you
know what i mean i can't even believe
this i'm the series i love you man fish
are delicious
yeah it's not racist fish are delicious
wrong this is what i made
this guy's got good style fish ain't
delicious all the time though
is that a cop's hat this guy don't got
hat head well you know coffee is back
you know cops is back nice it's on fox
is it really on demand but on fox makes
sense yeah yeah uh this guy's got to
sink my ink for us
boys i got a king of their stinging
incriminating tattoos
my boy steve might love this one you got
the old pervert on the thigh
to say i love purple it's a term
endearment but around the wrong people
it's a little sketchy
[Laughter]
great tattoo
that's a good i like it i i say get it
man
an inside joke but i wonder if he got it
though when he was like maybe a little
more i didn't got it like last week a
lot of senior citizens love that [ __ ]
that's what perhaps you probably can't
give me curvy stuff you can't probably
probably can't get my son's school with
that tattoo you feel me they're not in
guys with pervert type but a lot of uh
children who are seeing that like you
know in the summer you wear short shorts
well you can fill it up
make it a black part he could always
fill it in
yeah
this guy's got a king in our stinger for
us
what up king and the sting theo brandon
eric saw your laugh boston killed that
[ __ ] stevie bring the scissor bros to
boston all right i got a quick king of
the stinger for you guys so i'm
delivering some cremated remains today
what do we think making your mailman
deliver your dead loved ones let me know
guys
you know in the old days a family member
would take it and they would ride it out
to the family's
estates place of home that makes more
sense well i mean is he scooping some
out like what's you know what i mean
like if he's copping something that's
crazy i don't think he is he seemed like
an up-and-up dude well that's usps
and you're shipping like you're dead dad
yeah people are lazy i love how they put
cremated remains on yeah i wouldn't want
to know like a figure people would steal
that in a heartbeat by us
it's like can you like what if he like
he says somebody steals it and then they
like is there a ransom for this yeah you
know i got your dead grandpa sometimes
too you'll find a jewelry in there yeah
sometimes they cook them down and they
still got a jewelry on them yup or their
teeth so a lot of people steal that in a
heartbeat just to sift through it for uh
maybe a little ring or something
so i'm not saying this guy but a lot of
usps
usps if you order shoes if you're like a
sneaker head you're like off whites or
jordans or travis scott's those really
expensive shoes the box gives away
what's inside so nike had to change the
box because so many ups and usps drivers
were stealing the boxes
said to change the box well shipping
something's just crazed basically like
do you want to know that i like it
like i have this like
foolish faith that you know that's not
going to happen and people care about
their job and you know there's some
integrity to the mail service but it's
like damn knowing that is terrible which
are those sneakers worth
well now jeff scott's went down off
because he killed people but uh with
off-white those are through the roof
like a shoe i bought for
i got in chicago from some plug in
chicago for 700 it's going for like
eight grand now the new show is grand
wow the new traffic scots have blood on
them from that concept
and they come with more air take that
little nozzle that's crazy
that's that's seratiana that's her joke
actually
uh
but would you rather travis scott see
somebody steal those or you would you
rather steal travis scott or actually
tree steal travis scott remains
was he dead i don't know if he died i
didn't know you made i'm just not a
sneaker
yeah
some of the most exclusive
what's the most exclusive sneaker and
why
it's jordan
it's the same with like trading cards
you know how like they only made certain
jordan rookie cards or like certain
sneakers there's only like 50 of them or
like
there's certain jordans like they made a
m m jordan there's like two of them
they're like 50 grand yeah i saw a show
with like they had some like weird
jordans and the guy was like these are
fifty thousand dollars and i was like
what what i love the off whites and
virgil i've supported virgil for [ __ ]
ever i have so many off-whites and now
he passed away you know whatever but the
value of him went through the [ __ ]
roof
speaking of off-white
we'll close it out with this one hell
yeah dude aloha you look sick yo
taking this thing boys what's up got a
quick debate club for you guys today
you're a fan of the bath you know in the
bath right now you know the bathrooms
for the boys
you know
i'll have a bath every so often you know
after a long workout or you know maybe a
rugby game but you know
the shower is better everyone admits
that charlotte's better but do you guys
like baths come on
you're a fan
[Music]
of those are the boys when you're
bubbles with the boys in the uk
and you can't
well when you're as smooth as a seal i
love you guys
love you brother i love you young man
yeah that guy is hopefully doing okay
hey wait first of all he lived in his
beth of life so
yeah nice testimony nice too
i don't [ __ ] with that dude i i was
looking at houses i don't understand why
bath still it's still part of the
process who the [ __ ] uses bass some
chicks do
now
some older
no hot tub you don't get cleaned in a
hot tub you know you do though what's
the difference between a hot tub and a
hot bath
a hot tub it's circulating it's fresh
water it's circulating the water the
bath you're just sitting your own
[ __ ] no no you're taking a shower
first
yeah
so much first too much work and then you
get in the bath and get that and then
you take the shower even after the
bathroom
two showers we used to get our bodies
all hot in the shower when i was young
we'd get our bodies all hot me and my
brother and then drawing each other's
skin when it was so red remember try to
get the heat all the way up hot water
you'd be all red we get it all the way
to the max wow yeah
because you could catch that is that
called redneck finger paint
board as [ __ ]
redneck tattoos yeah that's right you
can condition your body to really
acclimate they couldn't
i don't [ __ ] with bass i don't like them
are you too big too i'm big too so like
if i go to a hotel i always take a bath
bomb with me just in case i'm at a hotel
oldest that they got it right yeah
i'm not the guy those are
yeah he drops that bomb yeah okay and if
it's a big like i was doing a movie in
boston i was staying at the uh the
mandarin oh damn all right
no netflix is the ones that yeah pay for
that
and the bathtub was like the mandarin
fruit it was a beautiful bathtub that i
fit in perfectly and there was a there
was a bath and body works right like a
block away so i just i got i was taking
baths all the time just laughing bombing
yourself
just lounging what flavors you had peach
you got some strawberry i might have had
a pizza this is the other thing when i
get in that that the water's just still
like that i get an erection man i'm
gonna have to jack off
maybe you have an issue man
maybe yeah you the problem yeah yeah
cause you can see the sperm swimming oh
no here we go
steve you know has an aquarium at home
he just keeps filling up stock in the
pond
check out my sea monkeys yeah
naming them looking at me like that's
it's sad man i know when we were kids we
did that not anymore okay stevie's gonna
get back up this week who had a who had
weirder things
redneck fingerprints definitely
probably had like a real ghetto of water
he can't do a pass to eight though yeah
yeah you gotta do that [ __ ] early it's a
daytime event yeah is it i'm not
shouting my brother at night like some
crete yeah
that's when it got romantic i mean it's
just you don't do what if you're in the
shower in the lights and then the sun
goes down oh you gotta get out i gotta
get it someone has gone all of a sudden
[Applause]
oh my god
hell no is that it nick that's it yeah
all right kids uh brendan and friends
mel's melrose uh off melrose it's the
hollywood improv that is december 22nd
hopefully
phil's probably not in town either way
it's uh shop and friends the friends
gonna be [ __ ] funny you guys know who
they are oh yeah i wasn't on the
american friends but that's all right
y'all had a good time there could be
online though i was in the lab you even
showed up there it could be on mine a
bunch of things had all these demands
you know what i'm saying
yeah you got writers for a lab show the
shop and friends december 22nd hollywood
improv december 22nd then dania florida
it's the fort lauderdale improv bringing
the new years with your thick friend
december 30th through january 1st all
right
that's fort lauderdale florida end of
the year let's ride this weekend i'm at
uh stand up live in arizona oh are you
really yeah
live la jolla la jolla was great yeah it
was great
all the shows were packed all the shows
were packed it was really good scissor
bros jeffersonville pennsylvania
february 3rd oxnard levity live bro no
one's coming to your street
where you're talking february 5th i'm
not coming huntington beach february 6th
irvine improv with jeremiah he told me
to tell he told me to say let me see
what mine are mine ours um
february 2nd jacksonville florida
the
butthole of florida right there
a lot of beautiful people there that i'm
excited to see
february
change for the money man
jacksonville a good place to get mugged
at a stoplight bro
you also got st petersburg florida
uh february 3rd orlando february 5th
then got rockford illinois february 26th
uh chicago
uh sorry were you playing in chicago i
think the shocking theater yeah that'd
be fun i've never been yeah friday
friday rockford saturday chicago
february 25th 26th and in tulsa and los
angeles
on sale now we were in los angeles
the wilton during the uh
some festival oh netflix festival yeah i
feel you doug oh we got fight companion
this weekend 7 p.m live pacific the
diamond fight companion
oh yeah y'all doing fighting you're
doing fighting pain dang you're in town
or what i'm going i'm going to be there
are you going to fight yeah all right
take it easy
here i might have to get in the ring
dawg if [ __ ] gets out of hand you're
gonna be in the front row with a mint
coat on i wish dude no he's always
bringing his son i would
you'll hear theo kate's side brandon
rip his head off your son is fancy as
[ __ ] though that's something fine as
hell too
my his
uh my girl did his hair like the island
boys i sent it to theo oh yeah beautiful
god beautiful all right love you guys
we're out
king
[Music]
back with the crew we got stevie weeby
eric griffin brendan vo2 yeah you know
how we do it so just tune in for the
laughs theo said that he was on his way
but ran out of gas
stevie weeby used to wrestle down at
parkway
now he only finished boys in the hallway
this ain't the greatest show on earth
and what you call that eric griffin with
them he the nate dogger podcast
[Music]
just walked in and got it lit you can't
forget about brendan he still need
everything dick dick they still got the
bees and the trap trapping still the
king in the sting so quit asking if you
know then you know it's a cat's thing
ball and chain hair swang like the rat
cane king and distinct
with the crew we got stevie weeby eric
griffin brendan theo too yeah you know
how we do it so just tune in for the
laughs theo said that he was on his way
but ran out of gas
[Music]
[Applause]
king and the sting
you